Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie big surprise James Gunn just came
right out and said who the new Superman is going
to be in Superman Legacy so we'll break it all
down he also announced the new Lois Lane they're
still casting Lex Luthor right now but we do
have a pretty close idea about who it's going
to be and there are a couple really solid picks
that they're looking at you got the part yes yes
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos obviously I'll
be doing videos for Superman legacy as we get
more news about the movie and what's happening
with James Gunn's new rebooted DCU the DC movies
I will address what's happening with The Flash
movie because that's meant to sort of tie
a bow on what's happening with the Snyder
versus movies but the big news that you probably
literally just saw in your feeds the last couple
of minutes is that David Cornswet is going to
be the next Superman in Superman Legacy he's
been my number one pick for the last couple of
months while they announced that this was going
to happen once James Gunn announced that he was
going to recast Henry Cavill with a new version
of Superman everybody was looking at David corin's
but there were a couple other people on the list
but for the most part he looked and he felt like
the part and a big part of that is actually a bit
of a change from Henry Cavill Superman is how much
more they're leaning on the Clark Kent side of the
character there was some Clark Kent that we saw
from Henry Cavill but for the most part you saw
him as Superman in the Snyder versus movies like
Man of Steel Batman v Superman in the Justice
League Snyder cut this is a really good example of
what David cornswets Clark Kent feels like to me
it's not about the notoriety it's about the craft
it's about showing up to work every day you know
and for a super that can mean sorry a what in many
ways we contribute to the reality of the scene
even more so than the principal actors but hey
I've got a casting tomorrow and if they pick me
that's ten dollars in my pocket did exactly what
we're doing now they're going through tons and
tons of actors to see who captures that Spirit the
thing they don't talk about much when they talk
about Christopher they talk about his pureness
his hope his goodness they talk about you know
the way that he plays Clark as being so different
from the way he plays Superman and how he can turn
that on in an instant nothing bye frisky long now
but there's this playfulness about Superman this
when he's saving a cat he's got that wry smile and
that is one of the best parts of the movie is the
playfulness of Superman he enjoys what he's doing
he likes helping human beings anyway right off the
bat that totally feels like what you would expect
Clark Kent to sound like and look like just put
a pair of glasses on him a couple years ago he'd
also been asked about Superman other big superhero
movies and talked a little bit about what the
character meant to him and this was back when
Henry Cavill was still expected to continue
to be Superman when they were still planning
on making Man of Steel too even then it sounded
like David corns but understood the character on
a fundamental level and to boot even though we're
talking about recasting Henry Cavill everyone's
kind of sad to see him go I would have wanted to
see Man of Steel too just because of what they had
planned for that with Brainiac but doesn't he look
like he could be Henry cavill's younger brother
so when Henry Cavill said that he was not going to
be Superman anymore but there were talks about him
possibly coming back in the future maybe for like
a crisis on infinite Earth movie they could also
bring him back as just the older version of David
cornsworth's Superman and I don't think they're
gonna plan to do that anytime soon it's still
going to be many years before James Gunn works up
to the end of his DC Phase One which are calling
DC chapter one The whole idea with this version
of Superman is that he's meant to be kind of like
an early Superman Superman Year too the same way
they did Robert Pattinson's Batman as Batman year
two like not at origin story but very early in his
days as the character very early after he started
to wear the cape and cow they also just confirmed
Rachel Brosnahan as the new Lois Lane which is
a bit of a surprise she was one of my original
picks but when they said that they were testing
the actors out the past couple of weeks they said
that David cornsworth's audition had been paired
up with Emma Mackey because they were testing
Superman and Lois Lane Clark Ken and Lois Lane
together to see what their chemistry was like
so a lot of people myself included assumed that
David korinswet would be their pick for Superman
meaning that Emma Mackey would potentially be
their Lois Lane but now it sounds like they like
his chemistry with Rachel Brosnahan better charges
her portrayal of what they want their Lois Lane
to be or what James Gunn wants his lowest Lane
to be recently James Gunn also talked a little
bit about what Superman as a character meant to
him how fundamentally how he viewed the character
and it sounds like he really does understand the
dichotomy between Clark Kent and Superman because
a lot of people talk about this when they're
talking about the differences between Batman
and Superman when you're talking about the Batman
character the whole idea is that Batman is who he
really is Bruce Wayne is the mask that he puts on
when he's out in public he pretends to be Bruce
Wayne he really is Batman whereas with Superman
it's reversed Clark Kent is who he really is when
he's just walking around being normal Superman is
the mask that he puts on and even though there was
some humor with Henry cavill's version of Superman
I do feel like that was a much more serious much
more grounded version of Superman that was the
whole point and one of the big differences with
James Gunn's Superman Legacy movie is that when
the events of the movie pick up superheroes will
already exist like metahumans will already exist
in the world whereas during the Man of Steel movie
it was sort of like an introduction to the whole
concept of aliens like oh my God aliens are real
then you started to see all these metahumans
proliferate the rest of the Justice League
characters with powers one of the other big
details about Superman Legacy is supposedly
the authority group is going to show up during
this Abdullah already exists during the events
of the movie because James got said they're going
to do a movie based on the Authority for those of
you that wanted to see those characters in live
action max is a big movie called The Authority The
Authority is a passion project of mine it's based
on The Marvelous Wild Storm characters we are now
bringing into the DCU and will interact with
all of our primary DCU characters The Authority
are a group of superheroes who think the world
is broken and they want to fix it by any means
necessary I think it's a very different look
at superheroes when we get more details about
the actual plot I'll do more videos about that
it's still pretty early days he's still casting
out the movie they're still looking at their Lex
Luthor right now too and it sounds like it might
end up being Bill Skarsgard he sounds like their
lead pick but the funny thing is is he's actually
testing against his brother Alexander Skarsgard
Skarsgard into the Skarsgard verse their father
Stellan Skarsgard is on Andor right now probably
gave one of the best speeches in all of Star Wars
history what's going on right now with the Flash
movie Blue Beetle and Aquaman 2 because those are
still coming out this year we just got The Flash
movie is it the supposedly using The Flash movie
to sort of tie a bow on the Snyder verse because
at the end of the movie The Flash changes history
again causing the timelines to overlap causing
a slightly less of a spaghetti mess but still
a bit of a mess he winds up in the Clooney verse
and overlapping with some of the things from the
original Justice League DC EU like this Aquaman
is meant to be the original Aquaman from the DC
EU so he has the same Powers same backstory and
it sounds like the events of Aquaman 2 will then
take place in this reality so we're no longer
in that original DC EU Snyder verse and because
the box office of The Flash is so low it sounds
like like there won't be any chance of a sequel
I just did a video about deleted scenes alternate
endings with Henry Cavill Superman other Justice
League characters Ben Affleck's Batman plans
that they had for the sequel like reverse flash
the other flash Rogues I'll put a link for that
in the description below but it sounds like what
will happen is that when James Gunn eventually
does do a new version of The Flash inside his
DCU it'll just be a completely recast version of
the character which I think everybody is fine with
just start fresh totally new actor you could even
do a version of Wally West the next big thing is
obviously figuring out what's going on with Batman
brave in the Bold in the new version of Batman
they're going to cast the older version of Batman
with the younger Damian Wayne the introduction of
the dcu's Batman is the Brave and the Bold the
Brave and the Bold is the story of Batman and
his actual son Damien Wayne this is based on Grant
Morrison's great comic book run Damien Wayne is my
favorite Robin he's a little assassin who Batman
tries to get in line and so this is the story of
the two of them and the beginning of sort of the
bat family in the DCU Andy muschietti is still
supposed to be directing that I feel like even
though the Flash movie bombed and everybody's kind
of bummed out about that one of the best things
about the movie is the way he did his versions
of Batman like the way he treated Ben Affleck's
Batman the way he filmed Michael Keaton's Batman
those felt like really solid parts of the film
like it was his test run to show James Gunn oh
you know how to do a Batman movie with a bunch
of money so here you go you do Batman brave in
the Bold everyone just let me know in the comments
though what do you think about David Cornswet is a
version of Superman obviously his Clark Kent seems
like it's going to be pretty solid but now we need
to see what he's going to look like as actual
Superman he's definitely got the build for it
I feel like he could bulk up Henry Cavill was way
smaller before the events of Man of Steel and even
Ben Affleck said that when they started doing
Batman v Superman together he actually started
working out with Henry Cavill to try and teach
him how to bulk up even more so if you wonder
why Henry Cavill got so much bigger between Man of
Steel and Batman v Superman and then the Justice
League movie and obviously The Witcher series is
sounds like he owes a lot of that to Ben Affleck's
help but I'm not expecting David cornsworth to
get quite as big as Henry Cavill Superman remember
this is also supposed to be a younger version of
the character so slightly less powerful the whole
idea with kryptonians is that the longer they
live the more powerful they get the more solar
radiation they absorb so you would expect the
older version of the character like the Henry
Cavill version of the character to be much bigger
much more powerful there's a bunch more stuff
coming this week so make sure to enable alerts for
my channel so you don't miss any of those videos
and I'll be posting my Secret Invasion Episode 2
video on Wednesday just like normal everyone click
here for that flash alternate ending alternate
post credit scene with Superman deleted scenes
and click here to learn about Ben Affleck coming
back as his Daredevil in Deadpool 3 in the Marvel
movies thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!